i used to feel
so much peace staring into the heavens
until a piece of it fell
and the nightmare began
we thought it could be contained
but it evolved so we
did too one of our own is m.i.a i need
an extraction team
[Music]
now
if there's a way to stop them
you will find it
[Music]
but i know
you will find me
first
okay i'll take out the nests
i have a signal let's go
stand back
clear let's move out
ticking
i found her
hey better hold on
[Music]
[Music]
coming through
[Music]
an apex
not so fast
cover me
hey you all throwing me a party
yeah dude you missed all the fireworks
team it's ash we're not done yet vip
down
[Music]
now i know you must have a ton of
questions after seeing that trailer
and we have answers as well as a full
gameplay walkthrough coming up
so hang tight my name is richard i'm
your resident community developer coming
to you from north carolina
we're thrilled to be back to give you an
introduction to rainbow six extraction
with me today in montreal i have bruno
lalon our lead technical director
and alicia fortier game designer to help
walk us through
alicia what can we tell our players
about extraction
extraction is a one to three player
co-op experience
you might think you know what you're
getting into since there's gonna be some
of your favorite rainbow six operators
but it's gonna be completely different
because this time you're not fighting
against each other you're
coming together to face an unprecedented
evolving
alien threat some of the operators
abilities
gadgets and tech should feel familiar to
siege players
but this time as you progress through
the game you'll unlock a new ability
upgrades
and a whole new arsenal specifically
designed to take on this new threat
so the operators we just saw in that
trailer are very familiar
but what happened to hibana she got
captured
an extraction you're always putting it
all on the line
if your teammate falls during an
incursion you're gonna go missing in
action
you can't play mia operators until
they're safely recovered
you and your squad are gonna have to
come back together to get back in there
and get them
out every time
you go in the containment zone you risk
losing all your progress
and upgrades so stay on your toes and
weigh
every move you make balancing that risk
and reward scenario is going to be tough
bruno can you tell us a little bit more
about the alien threat
what is it who are they and where do
they come from
what we know is the arkhams are evil
form
of the parasite that was first detected
few years ago
during the outbreak event in new mexico
but a lot have changed since
the parasite has spread to three new
regions emerging and several containment
zones
within new york san francisco and alaska
this is what we know so far within the
contentment zones
the alien ecostem is in a continual
evolution
as incubation nests and their sprawling
tissue
spawn procedurally taking over the front
area of the map
and reaction to the player presents the
parasite is always spreading
always evolving but it didn't look too
happy about the operators disturbing
their new home
what are we facing off against well the
black goo like sprawl
is probably the first thing you will
take on it spreads to the map
once your presence is detected slowing
your progress
and helping the arches some of the other
traits you may have seen on the trailer
are the long range spiker the explosive
creatures
the shape-shifting tormentors and the
epics
there's a lot more species of our kings
and mutations that have been observed
more to come on that very soon
thank you both so much for joining me
i'm really excited to dig into more of
the details
we still have crossplay to talk about
yes that's right
extraction will bring everyone together
regardless of the platform
and for our rainbow six siege community
we have exclusive unlocks for you
in both games okay you've been waiting
long enough
let's take an exclusive first look at
some gameplay footage
here is rainbow six extraction
welcome to rainbow six extraction the
new tactical co-op shooter game where
rainbow six operators are dropped into
alien territory
in today's walkthrough we're on a
mission to investigate anomalies
identified at the orpheus research
center in alaska
hq will provide additional instructions
we need new data on the parasites
underground network
it keeps evolving adapting plant auto
trackers on dormant nests
don't destroy them or will lose the
trackers
as a squad of three ella alibi and
sledge will use their operator abilities
to complete objectives
assist each other and obliterate
archaeans in their way
spinning up
that's a grunt easy for a nest to
incubate and bring to life
not so easy to eliminate in large
numbers converge on location
nice and quiet the enemy reacts to
intrusions in their ecosystems
including operators eliminate my target
so stealth tactics are the way to go
visual on nest place auto trackers for
our react scientists
auto tracker activated
[Music]
the parasite generates sprawl a
substance that connects the whole
ecosystem alert and archaean
and a nearby nest wakes up too our kians
move faster in sprawl but operators get
slowed down
take my guy out the squad can use their
react light to see bioluminescent
properties in archaeans and in the
environment
[Music]
the contrast helps to better identify
targets
[Music]
nest mapping complete
identifying our key invariants helps the
team determine the best approach to take
them out
[Music]
spotted a router it can immobilize
anyone in front of it
so sledge will swing around back
get out of there before the swarm
appears don't push your luck
go
that was close here the team can regroup
and resupply
airlock doors will open onto the next
subzone which will be tougher than the
first
we need tissue samples from those arches
and we need them gone
use your react blade
[Music]
[Music]
it's right there react blade do your
thing
one down we're not done yet
that's your target don't put it to death
just yet
get that sample we've located a spiker
it can fire armor-piercing projectiles
alibi deploys a prisma hologram
deploying the
the squad can use react tech to go
further in incursions
the more intel they collect the more
tech they'll have at their disposal to
fight off this threat
it's all about teamwork to outsmart the
enemy barricade that spot
reinforcing creating a chokepoint is a
good idea to increase the arc mine's
efficiency
that's the way keep hunting that's the
react threat sensor
smasher incoming
wow that did it take out the leader no
leader for the archies to follow
another objective completed the squad
can either x-fill at the extraction
point to bring home the latest intel
or move to the next airlock the third
subzone will be the most challenging yet
a true test of both tactical team
strategy and operator reflexes
arcanes are responding to an elite as if
they're communicating
no way we'd let them mobilize against us
hunt them down until the elite comes out
of hiding
[Music]
[Music]
contact
the elite will show up any second
enemy located
an operator is now m.i.a i don't know if
you can hear this but we're mounting a
rescue
hang tight
you heard it a rescue mission is
underway
react still needs you